je me disais quand et avec des gens
c'est toujours super gênant de s'isoler
pour aller aux toilettes
enfin quand tu vas faire pipi ça tu le
dis par contre quand on doit aller faire
plus que pipi c'est à dire qu'on doit
faire
et bah ça on ne dit jamais et donc il a
acheté une moto et le truc c'est qu'elle
était trop lourd pour lui où il avait
besoin mais voilà ces cinq là bas norman
tu vas où je reviens je vais je faire un
truc non mais comment ça tu vas faire un
truc je vais faire un truc dario de
répondre tu vas où ben ali peut nous
dire qu'est ce que tu vas bon ok je vais
faire caca comme ça c'est bon tout le
monde est au courant je peux y aller
merci c'est vrai que c'est la honte
d'aller faire c'est pour ça que moi
j'essaie de faire passer tous mes
passages aux toilettes pour des pipis
malin quand je vais chez une fille je ne
fais jamais parce que j'ai juste une
angoisse c'est eu la chance de ne marche
plus parce que forcément c'est obligé de
lui dire je crois que la chasse d'eau
marche plus ouais les gars c'est à et
comment je fais pour l'amérique
non mais je fais je le fais à l'attaqué
mais n'en fait pas partie ok donc c'est
toi qui ouais ouais c'est ça voilà cette
femme ne couchera jamais avec toi de
tout tu as dis moi si un jour ça
m'arrive je quitte le pays d'ailleurs
quand tu es en couple
au début de la relation c'est toujours
très gênant d'aller aux toilettes alors
qu'à ta copine parce que ça casse le
côté romantique
cependant il existe des petites
techniques notamment de la première
c'est de mettre un max de paix qu au
fond de la cuve est assez classique et
la deuxième qu'on a déjà tous fait c'est
de mettre la musique à un volume assez
puissant de manière à bien camouflé tous
les bruits
ah mais moi ce moment là j'ai toujours
peur qui est un stop dans la musique
pile poil au moment fatidique
ah et puis quand tu es en couple il ya
toujours ce fameux débat autour de la
cuvette
c'est chiant parce que moi quand je lève
pas la cuvette on me dit tu fais quand
même
et quand je lève la cuvette on me dit
elle donc moi j'ai trouvé une solution
la cuvette semi relevé heureusement les
smartphones ont réussi à faire ce que
les femmes essayent de faire depuis près
de 100 ans faire pisser les mecs assidus
vous le savez peut-être pas mais dans
les urinoirs
nous on fait pas que faire pipi on joue
aussi à des jeux
grand
500 points un autre truc super gênant
quand est posée aux toilettes c'est
quand tu reçois un appel professionnels
sur ton portable et que genre tu étais
obligé de décrocher
c'est dans ce cas là tu peux pas dire
que tu es aux toilettes c'est c'est ça
fait pas trop allô monsieur thabo je
vous dérange pas j'espère non vous ne
dérangez pas par contre je fais caca un
vraiment j'ai très envie
est ce que je peux vous rappeler plus
tard surtout il ya des bruits de brut
qui vont arriver
moi une fois comme ça j'ai décroché mais
j'aurai j'aurais absolument pas du web
très bien est ce que vous avez de quoi
noter là tout de suite je peux pas noté
non comment ça parce que je pars ce que
je sais pas écrire je moi je sais que
lire en fait je j'ai fait que la moitié
du cp je sais pas si vous avez eu
l'occasion de tester les toilettes
publiques dans les villes mais les mecs
qui ont créé ça ils ont quand même eu
l'intelligence la bonne idée de mettre
une petite voix qui commente le choix de
ta chasse d'eau quand tu sors de la
cabine d'aiguillage en cour les avait
sélectionné le mode grande chasse d'eau
félicitations ça devait être une très
grosse envie
à bientôt dans les toilettes publiques
oui c'est la petite voix des toilettes
publiques qui vous parle apparemment
vous avez choisi la grande chasse d'eau
vous êtes en direct sur nrj et les
stations c'est vrai que moi je vais même
pas dans la tête public en fait moi je
fais pipi dans la rue comme comme un
comme un gros porc partage ma fille tu
es sur ton mur facebook soit de poule
les
mois selon l'âge de bien tu perds timide
et le seul discours que j'arrive à
sortir c'est merci